über 25.000 Schafe Ziegen Rinder werden
derzeit von der kenianischen Regierung
geschlachtet das Fleisch wird an
familienverteilt die unter extremer
Mangelernährung leiten viel zu
schlachten ist in Afrika eigentlich ein
Ausdruck von Freude und Wohlstand das
Fleisch ist Gastmahl für Freunde oder
bei Hochzeiten jetzt ist es das nicht
mehr im nordkoreanischen samura wissen
sie sich nicht mehr anders zu helfen
eine Ziege kann von vier Haushalten
geteilt werden eine Kuh von 10 wir
können die Familie mit dieser
Hilfsaktion unterstützen in einer Zeit
von Dürre die anhalten wird
die Dürre das ist nicht nur hier ein
Problem sondern in ganz Ostafrika seit
über einem Jahr hat es nicht mehr
ausgiebig geregnet nichts wächst mehr
Mensch und Tier leiden unter
Wassermangel so hat sich Kenia
entschlossen geschwächte Tiere schon
jetzt zu töten
ich habe 30 Kühe die abgemagert sind
wegen der Dürre wenn es nicht bald
regnet ist das ein großer Verlust für
mich daher bin ich gekommen um meine Kuh
zu verkaufen
um einen Baum herumsitzen Frauen mit
ihren Kindern sie sind stundenlang in
der Hitze hierher gelaufen weil sie sich
Hilfe erhoffen Hilfe für ihre
mangelernährten Kinder
ich habe es ins Krankenhaus zur
Behandlung gebracht und mir wurde gesagt
es wiegt zu wenig
Patrick Dog ist Krankenpfleger im
nahegelegenen jilike Gesundheitszentrum
er versucht zu helfen wo er helfen kann
die jahrelange Dürre die Hitze die
Distanzen aber machen es schwierig die
meisten Familien haben nur noch Maismehl
mit Wasser gemischt davon ernähren sich
so was essen sie die meiste Zeit die
meisten bekommen keinen Obst weil es
hier keines gibt es ist einfach zu
trocken sie haben kein Gemüse wir haben
keine Früchte die Menschen essen einfach
Maisbrei
so Schlachten sie das Vieh das bringt
Einkommen für die Bauern Essen für
Menschen und es sind weniger Tiere die
um das bisschen Wasser kämpfen müssen es
mindert aber auch ihre Existenzgrundlage
und vor allem ist es eine Lösung für den
Moment von Dauer ist sie nicht
da ist alles sehr unsicher weil es nur
ab und zu passiert für heute wird es
helfen denn einer verkauft und einer ist
Fleisch und so können wir zumindest
einigen Haushalten helfen
ausgedörrte Böden soweit das Auge reicht
auch hier im Osten Kenias der Region
Turner River haben die Menschen seit
Monaten keinen ausgiebigen Regen mehr
erlebt die meisten sind sogenannte
pastoralisten sie Hirten sie leben von
ihren Tieren und zu ziehen sie Hunderte
von Kilometern um hier auf der Suche
nach Wasser
als wir mit unseren Herden hierher kamen
haben sie es nicht geschafft sich zu
akklimatisieren
ihre Gesundheit verschlechterte sich
massiv
wir leiden unter der Dürre und die
meisten der Tiere sind gestorben
die Frauen von Tana River laufen jeden
Tag zu einem kleinen Wasserbecken um
ihre Plastikgefäße zu füllen doch sie
können zusehen wie auch hier der Pegel
immer niedriger wird das
Welternährungsprogramm der Vereinten
Nationen fürchtet eine humanitäre
Katastrophe
schon jetzt sind 15 Millionen Menschen
am Horn von Afrika betroffen und
brauchen Nahrungsmittelhilfe wenn der
Regen weiter ausbleibt sagen wir voraus
dass über 20 Millionen von der Dürre
betroffen sein werden und
Nahrungsmittelhilfe brauchen
besonders hart trifft die Dürre die
kleinsten etwa 8 Millionen Kinder
zwischen 5 und 15 Jahren so schätzt
UNICEF sind vom Hungerstod bedroht sie
haben keine Kraft mehr in ihren
ausgemergelten Körpern um überhaupt noch
zu einer hilfsstation zu gehen die
gestiegenen Lebensmittelpreise schlagen
sich auch auf die Liefermengen der
Hilfsorganisationen nieder
wir haben gesehen wie die Energiepreise
durch die jüngste internationale
Entwicklung hochgegangen sind auch die
Kosten der Nahrungsmittelproduktion
besorgen und sehr und sie werden weiter
ansteigen
im Bürgerkriegsland Somalia kommen zu
der Dürre Vertreibung und Flucht hinzu
die Menschen fliehen vor marodierenden
Banden geben ihre kleinen Farmen auf und
hoffen darauf irgendwo Hilfe zu bekommen
Hasan abdulcoran lief mit seiner Familie
hunderte von Kilometern die Dürre hat
ihm alles genommen
die Dürre in der Gegend verschlimmen und
kein Regen was immer wir auch gepflanzt
haben ist nicht gewachsen
die Kinder von fatuma Adam Gusow haben
die Flucht knapp überlebt ihre Mutter
sah nur einen Ausweg den in das
Flüchtlingscamp Dolo im Westen Somalias
als das Essen auf unserem Hof
aufgebraucht war und die Tiere zu
sterben begannen konnten wir unsere
Kinder nicht mehr versorgen der Hunger
hat uns zur Flucht gezwungen
ausgiebigen Regen das ist worauf die
Menschen am gesamten Horn von Afrika
hoffen doch für die nächsten Monate
sieht es nicht danach aus und das könnte
die Versorgungslage in ganz Ostafrika
dramatisch verschlechtern